welcome to this video 15 minute game h z
MC russia all right yes and Charlotte
seem 15-minute chess what could I play
okay let's let's do the bottle I mean I
should know something about it let's see
what happens 22 very early Quincy to him
interesting maybe it's trying to prepare
your form yeah my general plan is small
related to d65 so I'm not sure if I want
to play d5 it's probably not bad yeah
okay let's stay within this within this
territory with d65 you can't play you
for now now in one move though which is
a bit a bit uncommon to allow that okay
well 96 I could transpose to to the
zurich variation of the quincy to new
zone with an early a five though which
is not a problem but not Nocturne essa
sara lee necessary necessarily necessary
this is great um okay it's not let's say
essential to play it play 85 early when
the night is on c6 but I can also play
that video 7 this is not not bad at all
preparing a five in this way hmm
interesting
I really expected him to play for you
three but okay you can do that that's no
problem can t takes you from this is
very very modest move young at the time
Knight takes was also possible of course
didn't want to exchange so many let's
say even more pieces interesting I'm
tending to room 94 maybe yeah okay I
don't mind that the question what to do
now okay why does not really really am
able to fight for an action this manner
but he's very solid of course
check okay so we have some trades hmm
yeah of course here the the bishops are
the important pieces because them
activity of those pieces pretty much
determine what's going on in the next
couple of moves c5 is an interesting
really interesting yes hmm it sort of
isolates the b4 porn from my from my
forces so it must be must be cautious
that I keep this pawn okay let's go here
there should be successor something that
I need to prepare I need to cover the b7
point I'm thinking about Queen d5 a b5
sorry in p5 to keep some pressure
against the c5 pond and then maybe
Bishop e6 Brooke a7 those moves before
might be a weakness but it also allows
some play on the queenside a move that
you can play here is a 3 threatening to
nice are threatening to take yeah this
is also possible hmm let's sing let's
think for a moment yeah taking us
nonsense so I need to move it yeah I
don't really see how I can allow him to
take so let's go b6
and now I've got many points on dark
squares which is the good thing with the
bishop on c8 so there should be six
would be this would sit very nicely only
six yeah there was this this is a move I
had seen the idea but I didn't really
have any opportunity to to prevent it
the question is how dangerous is it
really Jim I cannot really take
hmm you have the problem is that there
is a very quickly at five coming how do
I respond to that
hmm
okay hmm this is probably really bad
young it's very tough to ever take it
Wow
that's really hard I need any way to
defend this Wow
mm yeah really Queen a five and Bishop
before this kind of attacks are the
problem
one problem is after the capture pawn
takes rook da that he immediately can
take c7 I could try be three be three
mmmm cueing takes takes on g7 cd7 and
rook the eight takes on a eight and if
he takes it's not clear that you must do
that takes Queen takes van g7 hangs and
if you covers it with rookie one Quincy
six can still but with 23 keep the pond
now after b3 Queen takes I cannot take e
to because this hangs great hmm
if he takes on c7 the next smoother rook
does not have squares this is important
queen bee hive maybe queen bee five
threatening be three years a counter
play and yeah maybe okay I need to move
at some point but whatever happens I
need to move he had lots of time now to
check okay some things are not good like
Bishop d5 I can take on d 7 hmm i can go
Queen f5 of course but if I go look f8
it's somewhat like it's a bit of a self
pin of the rook okay and I'm threatening
to take these seven so okay maybe maybe
this is still a move that somehow keeps
the game going maybe I should have
really found this a bit quicker or
carrot I mean I'm not sayin I'm great
here maybe he has a direct direct kill
so it wouldn't be really surprising yes
this is this is certainly possible I
came but now
we can to take on a two it's not really
helping takes takes our Creator
membership is winning immediately so
this is not not really really helping
okay yeah still the c7 hanging I take a
two he just has rocked the area and have
no move this is not playable
grenade for maybe yeah he still okay can
go and he cannot go clean a five because
of Queen texty one this is a little
trick at least if he takes rook takes
rook c7.r okay too maybe maybe some
counter play now but he can probably
they are probably lost anyway at least
it looks very very difficult b3 I can
take a two after the Queen tried worked
yet i can go loopy a this should be
still playable maybe I'm not not very
confident here never dared this some
tricks I mean let's say Quincy for I can
also take this ever and he needs to
recapture with the rook dynasty one
hangs so they I list some tricks and
clean a five quindi one yeah not sure
what's best here maybe you can really
just take everything take a fort XD
seven and but it's not it's not so clear
Howie Howie should continue after that
the look on this on c7 does not have any
square to go to at least them without
any any exchange psych involved
ok
yeah the bad thing is that this record
so cuts off my bishop even if usually if
he takes it at some point and I can play
Bishop e6 at least this feels like a
position I mean okay I need to take okay
if I take now maybe then queena five but
ok this is a self-penned with Luca fade
let this happen ok maybe I have some
counter play the problem on b3 is not
not perfect as well I mean if it takes
Bishop e6 I'm quickly on the spawn
hmm yeah even from a very dull position
who had at first a very complicated game
can can arise
okay probably have to play row cafe diem
okay I as I just see that he has a look
at seven on okay but I have a counter
play at the end right I have a
counter-plan her taking taking us really
unplayable all right yeah it's card rook
f7 rock f7 rock f7 group THX King h7 or
even as Sam ok Bishop move no Queen
takes I have a counter play with Queen B
1 check Bishop f1 and Bishop age three
maybe this is good enough for a draw at
least oh it's not doing any of that just
piling up here but this now if I take a
frog the aid it needs to take with the
porn
hmm yeah let's let's grab it and rook da
I guess is threatening to take and
someone must do that Oh John the bone is
obviously strong but I'm not really sure
that I'm losing here or anything is it
is not exactly great but maybe maybe
playable Quincy seven I can take it too
until the Rope does not have a great
square yeah I don't know I feel it it
could have been even worse
yes this is what i thought just to just
to keep keep the screws on what now
Queen B 2 C 3 or something ok let's try
to play quickly if it takes before I
take e to and Quincy 3am and if i get if
i get the Queen's off I should be
alright I mean was he going to f3 maybe
yeah maybe at least 23 is not working
about it too was hanging here it was
singing I'm taking that
hmm
going for Quincy five yeah white is not
really threatening anything it's just a
bind you can put put the rock on a
three-year but this is not really do
much three minutes I can go f5 now right
f55 rope tags is his tied to the to the
bishop and Bishop check I I moved the
king and g7 Dennis hanging and I think
I'm close to being out of the woods here
I don't I don't really see a move at the
moment to be honest I mean a really good
one he can trade Queens with Quincy for
25 but this is some obviously not on
widest dreaming about
I don't see I don't see a good move on
really this was very very uncomfortable
and probably bad
yeah i don't i don't see a move really
it's funny nothing nothing great it's
summer always hanging
yeah this position after Queen B 5 and
Queen a form and move 20 have 1920 this
is probably the key where an improvement
is probably somehow winning the game
side ja I am I'm not not sure what
exactly but ok I can also play G 6cm
don't need to do anything fancy Rock f6
was also possible
just intending to I can take it
intending to approach approach with the
King and I can I Africa f 6m and rope d6
okay how many points is that so quite a
number I've got good 797 points that's
really a lot check
check
yeah he certainly a chances that that's
clear check
check-check
white resigns yeah he played played a
really dangerous stuff that's very
interesting to check this this position
here look do seven really was a shotgun
yeah I vaguely saw the idea but can i
buy almost took five minutes here let's
see here the computer wants to play rook
a7 with the substantial edge for wide
yeah don't know Quinn be five best move
according to the computer truck 81 this
is what he played and now I played here
so what is winning yeah the simple
captures winning yeah I don't know I
needed to do something i didn't i didn't
really see any any defense probably
there isn't isn't one what you should do
is to take and just take him yes and as
i mentioned it's the case he cannot it
does not have any squares to go to with
the rook but she also does not need to I
mean it's not I cannot attack the rook
and white simply can play Bishop g5 yeah
and it's just a win very relatively easy
okay so it continued so with the big
edge for wide and here Roxy seven yeah
yeah this is probably not good just take
it on c7 I can
yeah i can i can take here but this is
just much more dangerous than the beep
on it's in fact hard to defend
especially if you look at c7 there
should be seven at some point this is
completely winning and this probably not
young I can now I can play this position
it's so not not very comfortable to play
but okay this seems to be good and now I
take him yeah it's probably over with
the compensation it's not apparent how
wide should should increase the pressure
and no f5 and deathless this kills kills
it completely yeah you had the chance to
take on to 72 times at least two times
and this was was basically winning the
game what does this actually mean that
means that he I need to improve as after
here c6 I really don't know what else to
play he is threatening to take on b7 and
then take on c7 so I don't really see a
move besides be sick so this means that
Queen a success it's not good this is a
engine suggestion yeah that's not bad
attacking the pond maybe something like
that yeah lets us probably okay Joe
that's really slightly tricky I mean one
I i played Knight f6 also to keep bit
more tension in the position in terms of
equality I can just do that this is
really completely dead now I don't have
the double porn I wanted to have a
double so that I can maybe use the a
file at this this type of position is
just completely equal and white Eve
needs to be a bit a bit talk a bit
cautious as here he's got stuff on the
right squares I mean it still should be
drawn but yeah this is this is probably
better but since not not ambitious at
all but probably better than the game
okay thanks for watching